notre invité politique ce matin c'est
emmanuelle wargon bonjour bonjour
beaucoup d'être avec nous il est délégué
chargé du logement on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale vont enfin voir donc bonjour
fait des journaux du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on commence par l'actualité
madame la ministre et l'actualité ce
sont ces deux drames de drames qui ont
suscité de l'émotion et de la colère
chez les français on va commencer par ce
qui s'est passé à avignon et ce policier
éric masson tué en plein centre ville
dans une opération anti drogue
est ce qu'il y à encore aujourd'hui une
autorité de l'état dans notre pays
d'abord je voudrais dire à quel point je
m'associe à la douleur de la famille de
ce policier et toute la grande famille
de la police et des forces de l'ordre
c'est vraiment un drame terrible et
notre réponse doit être sans faille
c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'est rendu sur place le
soir même
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup renforcer
les moyens de la police plus de
policiers nous avons beaucoup augmenter
les moyens de lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants
nous devons rester 100% mobilisée c'est
ce que nous faisons
gérald darmanin quand il s'est rendu à
avignon il dit que la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants c'est une sorte de
guerre
est-ce que du coup nos policiers
aujourd'hui ils sont suffisamment armé
ou ceux propres sont figurés pour mener
cette guerre
en tout cas c'est un combat que nous
menons jour après jour l'importance et
que l'autorité de l'état
la force de la loi puisse être respecté
par tous quel que soit l'endroit quel
que soit le territoire de la france je
pense que c'est ça qui est essentiel il
ya un autre drame évidemment qui a
suscité la aussi l'émotion et la colère
de la population c'est cette jeune femme
qui a été brûlée vive à mérignac devant
chez elle par son ancien compagnon elle
avait alerté les forces de l'ordre elle
avait porté plainte il avait été
condamné il avait fait de la prison pour
violences conjugales
comment on peut encore en arriver là
aujourd'hui dans notre pays est là aussi
c'est un crime abominable enfin
quasiment insoutenable
j'ai aussi bien sûr une pensée pour la
famille de cette jeune femme là les
ministres ont été extrêmement rapide ils
ont demandé tout de suite une inspection
je pense que c'est indispensable il faut
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
précisément dans la chronologie des
failles des choses qui ne marchent pas
si on demande une inspection c'est pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé donc je ne
vais pas répondre à la question le
rapport d'inspection arrive rapidement
ça doit vraiment devenir une propre une
priorité par don de tous nos services
des services de police des forces de
l'ordre des services judiciaires c'est
aussi un réflexe à intégrer beaucoup
plus il y un risque lorsqu'une personne
sort de prison il faut qu'elle reste
accents contrôle judiciaire tout ceci
doit vraiment être regardé très présent
on va parler la réponse pénale mais sur
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
il ya des choses qui ont été faites
notamment dans le grenelle des violences
conjugales il ya des mesures qui ont été
mises en place notamment le bracelet
anti rapprochement il ya les téléphones
grave danger aussi sauf que là on voit
bien dans cette affaire que lui n'avait
pas de bracelet qu'elle n'avait pas de
téléphone grave danger
est-ce que du coup il n'y a pas des
failles dans l'application des
dispositifs d'abord le président de la
république ses gouvernements successifs
notre majorité est vraiment celle qui
s'est attaquée à ce sujet avec la grande
cause du quinquennat avec ce grenelle
des violences faites aux femmes avec
toutes les mesures que vous rappelez
après chaque cas et est un cas
évidemment de trop chaque cas est un
drame
il faut que nous comprenions comment
est-ce que ces mesures se diffuse je
n'irai pas plus loin sur ce cas
particulier mais vraiment je partage
l'horreur qui nous a tous saisis
quand nous avons appris l'existence de
ce drame mais sans parler de ce cas
particulier il faut travailler sur
l'application concrète sur le terrain
des dispositifs bien sûr ils ont
travaillé sans relâche mais c'est vrai
pour toutes les politiques publiques il
faut travailler sans relâche pour que
les décisions prises soient appliquées
partout
et justement on va parler de la réponse
judiciaire parce que finalement ces deux
drames il pose une seule et même
question est ce qu'aujourd'hui l'art
pons judiciaire dans notre pays elle est
à la hauteur et encore une fois je dis
j'ai du mal à généraliser à partir de
deux affaires et puis par ailleurs comme
vous le savez je ne suis pas en charge
de la des institutions judiciaires
ce que je vous dis c'est que nous devons
être très clair dans notre soutien aux
forces de l'ordre d'un côté dans notre
soutien aux femmes victimes de violence
de l'autre et que c'est ce qui guide
notre action au quotidien et finir par
l'enjeu politique à cette question de la
sécurité on a deux cas particuliers on
sait qu'à chacune des élections
présidentielles qui se sont déroulées
ces 20 dernières trente dernières années
il ya eu un fait divers qui a provoqué
un électrochoc dans l'opinion pour vous
c'est quand même un enjeu important ces
questions de sécurité la sécurité c'est
l'une des priorités des français c'est
l'une de leurs grandes demandes c'est
peut-être le dossier qui arrive au début
de leurs préoccupations avec la suite de
la crise sanitaire bien sûr les
conditions économiques et la lutte
contre les inégalités dans la campagne
francilienne laquelle je participe
puisque je suis candidate avec laurent
saint martin la première proposition qui
a été faite par le rang saint martin 7
une proposition autour de la sécurité
sécurité à l'échelle régionale notamment
sécurité dans les transports
donc oui cette préoccupation elle est
forte elle est forte dans toutes les
catégories de population et donc c'est
important qu'on y réponde
on va parler d'un autre sujet
un sujet sur lequel vous intéresser
particulièrement ces led faite aux
jeunes
hier l'assemblée nationale a rejeté une
proposition de loi du député de la
france insoumise françois ruffin pour
élargir le rsa aux jeunes vous vous y
êtes opposé à l'élargissement du rsa aux
jeunes est-ce que c'est chez vous une
conviction profonde
ou est ce que c'est une forme de loyauté
vis-à-vis du gouvernement moi je suis
absolument convaincu de deux choses la
première c'est que nous devons aider nos
jeunes à partir d'un accompagnement qui
est un accompagnement de parcours les
aider à trouver leur place dans la
société soit avec de la formation
initiale continuer ses études soit avec
de la formation professionnelle soit
grâce à des services civiques soit grâce
à des parcours d'insertion renforcer et
ça ça n'est pas le rsa jeunes parce que
le rsa qui est une politique que je
connais bien pour avoir contribué à la
transformation du rmi en rsa il y à une
quinzaine d'années c'est d'abord une
allocation avec un accompagnement qui
est plus ou moins bien mis en place en
fonction des situations locales et des
départements donc je suis réellement
opposé au rsa jeunes parce que le rsa
jeunes
ça veut dire une prestation qui commence
dès 18 ans et avec finalement assez peu
d'accompagnement je pense que
l'accompagnement doit primer après je
pense également qu on a besoin d'aller
plus loin dans dans notre filet de
sécurité
parce que même si nous avons beaucoup de
dispositifs d'accompagnement aujourd'hui
et notamment la garantie jeunes et la
garantie jeunes je les crée quand
j'étais délégué général à l'emploi et à
la formation professionnelle en 2013
mandaté par jean marc ayrault donc même
si nous avons des dispositifs il y à ce
qu'on appelle des trous dans la raquette
et donc moi ce que je propose c'est un
revenu gîte qui permet ensuite d'entrer
dans un dispositif d'accompagnement
c'est quoi un dispositif
d'accompagnement alors vous le disiez
vous êtes candidate aux élections
régionales en ile-de-france et dans ce
cadre là vous proposer l'instauration
d'un revenu d'urgence pour ces jeunes
c'est quoi les a conquises activement et
6 m en suis candidate aux élections
régionales en île de france avec laurent
saint martin sous la bannière territoire
de progrès et avec territoire de
territoire de progresser l'ailé gauche
de la majorité un jeu schématisme à la
fait et avec territoire de progrès nous
proposons un revenu d'urgence qui permet
d'aller vers les grands dispositifs
d'accompagnement très concrètement des
jeunes en grande difficulté - j'en
rencontre y compris dans les centres
d'hébergement d'urgence dont j'ai la
charge des jeunes qui dorment à la rue
dorment dans leur voiture ne savent pas
où aller n'ont aucun revenu
ces jeunes là il faut leur permettre
d'avoir accès à revenu quelques semaines
quelques mois au niveau du rsa le temps
de leur permettre de rentrer soit dans
la garantie jeunes soient en formation
soit en service civique en fait dans
toutes les solutions qui sont portées
par le gouvernement dans le plan un
jeune une solution donc je n'ai pas en
prennent bien ça n'est pas un nouveau
revenu qui couvrirait pour une période
longue
c'est le maillon qui manque c'est le
moment de solidarité qui manquent
entre le moment où vous avez un jeune en
grande détresse et le moment où il a
finalement intégré soit la garantie
jeunes qui est un accompagnement très
fort par les missions locales puis un
retour à l'emploi soit des études sous
un stage de la formation professionnelle
soit un service civique soit une autre
solution mais il vient pour cela veut
dire ça veut dire que en fait y'a pas un
nombre de mois précis ça veut dire que
ça va dépendre en fonction du jeune le
nombre de mois ça va dépendre font qu'à
leurs situations de chaque gène c'est à
d'abord tous ces dispositifs toutes ces
avancées sociales que ce soit le rsa ou
la garantie jeunes ont été expérimentées
et testé et moi ce que je propose c'est
qu'on le test qu'on expérimente gîte à
l'échelle d'une région mais du bourg
mois il faut il faut une durée courte
parce que l'idée ça n'est pas entre
guillemets de s'installer dans une
nouvelle prestation
c'est juste d'avoir un sas un moment qui
permet de vous aider à aller vers
l'étape d'après donc pour mesurer quelle
sera la même pour tout le monde
probable en tout cas ça devrait être
limitée à 3 mois peut-être six mois
maximum est la même pour tout le monde
c'est pas en fonction de chaque
situation et du moment où il va en fait
l'idée c'est que le jeune en question on
puisse lui proposer une solution pérenne
le plus vite possible
donc l'idée c'est que ce revenu soit
potentiellement très court peut-être
juste quelques semaines le temps de
laisser au système d'accompagnement le
temps de se mettre en place
est ce que ces trois mois maximum à ce
que ces quatre à mon ami travaillant
aller au delà de six mois mais de toute
façon ça va faire partie des paramètres
d'expérimentation il faut le tester pour
voir ce qui fonctionne et ce qui ne
fonctionne pas et du coup c'est 500
euros ils seront versés par qui puisque
vous le tester au niveau de la région
ils seront versés par la régie serait
financée par la région
bien sûr et ensuite ils pourraient être
versés soit par les grandes associations
de lutte contre l'exclusion qui sont en
général celles qui sont en contact de
ces jeunes soit par un guichet que la
région pourrait choisir par exemple les
caisses d'allocations familiales de
l'intérieur donc ces associations
seraient internet ça serait une option
ça aussi je pense que ça se teste donc
pour le moment vous voulez le tester au
niveau de la région est ce que vous en
avez parlé avec le premier ministre et
le président de la république on
imaginait ce qu'ils sont favorables à ce
que cette expérimentation s'élargissent
et laisser façonner one moi je fais
cette proposition comme candidate aux
élections régionales en île de france
avec laurent saint martin qui est notre
tête de liste et c'est aussi une
proposition je propose à d'autres
candidats et la presse chaque liste de
la majorité présidentielle est
souveraine j'en ai parlé à notre
candidat en bourgogne franche comté par
exemple denis thuriau j'en ai parlé à
notre candidat en normandie bonnaterre
je pense que c'est important que je sois
sont défavorables ça fait partie des
idées dont on discute vous savez et
c'est peut-être l'un des points qui est
le plus important pour moi
nos candidature aux régionales sont des
candidatures avec des plateformes
d'idées de solutions précises pour les
habitants des régions dans lesquelles
nous portons nos candidatures et donc
c'est aussi à chaque liste de se décider
pour savoir si ça les intéresse ou pas
mais je crois qu on partage tous avec le
président de la république avec le
premier ministre avec le gouvernement
avec nos candidats l'idée d'aller un
cran plus loin pour les jeunes et après
il ya plein de manières possible de le
faire et je pense que c'est intéressant
de territorialiser alors si vous
partagez avec le président de la
république l'idée d'aller encore plus
loin pour les jeunes est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il va annoncer de nouvelles
mesures pour les jeunes dans les
prochaines semaines mais ça je
laisserais au président de la république
le soin de faire les et l'a donc en
avait d'autres exploits selon les
informations d'europe 1 il pour annoncer
une aide de 500 euros par mois pour les
moins de 25 ans qui n'ont ni formation
ni emploi est ce que c'est une piste sur
laquelle vous travaillez le gouvernement
réussit c'est la même logique c'est dire
accompagner les jeunes pour ne laisser
aucun jeune sans solution et faire en
sorte que le revenu soit possible
systématiquement quand il n'ya pas de
revenus donc tout ça c'est vraiment la
même philosophie et le gouvernement
travail sur des annonces prochaine votre
silence en dit on dit quand même un peu
long on va parler de la loi climat
maintenant
emmanuelle wargon après le vote des
députés les sénateurs son pardon de
cette loi climat vous serez auditionné
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine par les
sénateurs sur ce sujet parmi les mesures
phares elle vous concerne cette mesure
c'est l'interdiction progressive de la
location des passoires thermiques
c'est une interdiction on trompe l'oeil
a fustigé l'opposition lors de l'examen
du texte à l'assemblée nationale avec
notamment cette question pourquoi ne pas
avoir obligé tous les propriétaires à
rénover leur logement alors c'est ce
qu'on fait on oblige les propriétaires
des passoires thermiques à rénover leurs
logements pour les louer et sur cette
question de l'obligation n'est pas très
élevé alors sur cette question
sémantique
moi j'ai eu une grande satisfaction au
moment du débat à l'assemblée nationale
qui est finalement cet article qui
interdit à la location les passoires
thermiques a été votée à l'unanimité il
a été voté par tous les groupes ce qui
montre bien que finalement tout le monde
est convaincu que c'est une avancée dans
la bonne direction
très concrètement les passoires
thermiques donc les logements les moins
bien isoler les pires ceux qui sont en
étiquette g seront interdits à la
location 2025 les étiquettes f en 2028
et les étiquettes eux en 2034 et l'autre
à bas les autres on va on va déjà rénové
tout cela ce sera déjà très bien
c'est quand même les consommations vrai
énergétique vraiment très élevés ça veut
dire que à compter de ces différentes
dates on ne peut plus publier une
annonce pour mettre en location à
logements de ce type et que si le
logement est mis en location quand même
c'est interdit par la loi et le
locataire a les moyens de se retourner
contre le propriétaire
on a eu des débats juridiques sur quelle
est la bonne manière juridique décrire
ça et si on avait écrit le le bail ne
peut pas il ne peut pas y avoir de bail
sur un logement de ce type
en fait on en écrit quelque chose qui
potentiellement ne protège pas le
locataire parce que ça veut dire que si
on constate que le bail est illégal le
bail est nul
auquel cas le locataire peut
éventuellement se retrouver sans contrat
de location donc potentiellement à la
rue
demain alors que là ce que nous avons
écrit permis aux locataires dans cette
situation d' exiger du propriétaire de
faire des travaux éventuellement d'aller
saisir un médiateur puis la justice si
nécessaire donc c'est en fait plus
protecteur pour le locataire et c'est
pour ça que nous n'arrivons à cannes sur
les moyens de se retourner
contre leur propriété en fait je vise
les locataires qui ne le ferons pas
parce qu'ils sont dans une situation
favori de fragile une situation de
faiblesse moi je trouve que ces débats
sont intéressants mais pourquoi est-ce
que c'est sur cet article de loi que
tout le monde se demande comment on fait
pour que la loi soit appliquée quand on
vote une loi c'est parce qu'on pense
qu'on saura la faire appliquer donc
c'est vrai pour énormément de textes de
dispositions de savoir comment on fait
pour que les plus fragiles est vraiment
recours au mécanisme protecteur
là c'est une interdiction claire avec
une possibilité de recours les caisses
d'allocations familiales pourront être
en appui aux locataires qui ont des
difficultés
c'est aussi le cas des équipes
départementales des fonds de solidarité
logement donc on trouvera les modalités
les grandes associations qui
accompagnent les locataires l'anil les
adil par exemple tout ce réseau se
mettra au soutien mais déjà aujourd'hui
le décret d'essence c'est le même
mécanisme qui interdit la location d'un
logement de moins de 9 mètres carrés qui
interdit la location d'un logement sans
point d'eau finalement ces locations
elles n'ont pas totalement disparu parce
qu'on a toujours des marchands de
sommeil mais elles sont quand même
devenu beaucoup plus limité donc moi je
crois que ça fonctionnera mais qu'est-ce
qu'il va ça c'est pour les propriétaires
qui ont des locataires de longue durée
puisque l'aï laissé des questions bail
sur les
il ne s'applique pas aux baux en cours
des graines à plat au renouvellement des
bouquets ce qui va se passer jusqu'au et
l'obligation sera effectif sur le
nouveau bail mais de toute façon et
c'est peut-être le point le plus
important nous allons accompagner les
propriétaires pour faire des travaux ma
prime rénove s'ouvre aux propriétaires
bailleurs
et puis la loi climat va mettre en place
un accompagnement mon accompagnateur
rénove pour tous les propriétaires
qu'ils soient occupants ou bailleurs et
cet accompagnement va les aider à
définir les travaux à faire et comment
les finances donc ça démarre maintenant
on à 1,8 million de passoire thermique
de logements mal isolés locatif à
rénover d'ici 2028 et on sera en
capacité de le faire
un mot sur un dernier mot sur cette loi
puisque vous l'avez vu à l'assemblée
nationale droite et gauche ont été assez
critique sur ce texte est ce que du coup
vous redoutez le passage de ce texte au
sénat
non je le redoute pas on a eu des débats
intéressants et importants sur mes
parties notamment mais sur la totalité
du texte à la fois sur la rénovation et
sur la lutte contre l'artificialisation
le texte a progressé à l'assemblée
nationale je sais que les sénateurs sont
extrêmement mobilisés sur les questions
de logement
on a des débats réguliers donc je pense
que le débat sera intéressant et
justement va parler mouvement avec
fabrice oui la crise sanitaire a un
impact clair sur le marché immobilier
notamment et qui englobe cette question
du logement est ce que vous pensez que
notamment la baisse des prix
milieu urbain dans pas mal de grandes
villes en france va être l'occasion de
re permettre aux familles de revivre
dans ses vignes d'abord je crois qu'il
faut être prudent sur les perspectives
du marché immobilier parce que je pense
que c'est un peu tôt pour avoir une
vision sur les tendances des prix après
ce serait effectivement une bonne
nouvelle s'il se confirme que les prix
dans les grandes villes se stabilise
moi je suis également favorable à
l'encadrement des loyers qui a été mis
en place à paris à lille et pour
lesquels d'autres collectivités ont
demandé à rentrer parce que ça me paraît
bien que voilà le les prix se
stabilisent dans les villes dont les
prix sont les plus élevés après la crise
pose une question de savoir comment et
où les français veulent habiter plus des
espaces plus d'espacés extérieurs
mais quand même besoin d'avoir accès à
des services d'avoir accès à des
transports en commun des mobilités
douces tu as des pistes cyclables
donc en fait c'est une question
d'aménagement urbain et d'aménagement du
territoire qui nous est posée et c'est
un travail auquel je réfléchis avec
france ville durable par exemple la
blinde et l'entreprise en direction de
votre ministère dans la façon d'imaginer
le logement des prochaines années en
france cette crise sanitaire
cette crise elle est un révélateur en
fait elle est un accélérateur de
tendance qui était déjà là parce que on
a un paradoxe potentiel qu'il faut qu'on
dépasse d'un côté les français en plutôt
envie de s'éloigner des grandes villes
est d'avoir le plus d'espacé possible
c'est normal de préférence une maison
avec un jardin quand c'est possible mais
de l'autre les mêmes on demande un accès
aux services que ce soit des commerces
de proximité des services publics et par
ailleurs pour des raisons écologiques on
a besoin de ne pas trop consommer de
nouvelles terres naturelles et agricoles
donc plutôt de trouver une forme de
densité acceptable agréable à vivre et
cette densité agréable à vivre qui n'est
ni la super densité des tra grandes
villes ni un habitat très éclatée qui
sont que des maisons individuelles très
répartis en grande périphérie
ce modèle là on a besoin de continuer à
l'inventer parce que on construit moins
en france depuis la crise les permis de
construire sont reculés et les mises en
chantier ont reculé et on a toujours des
besoins de logement donc il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver la bonne manière de
construire et la bonne manière de créer
de la ville ou de l'habitat à toutes les
échelles dans les grandes villes dans
les banlieues dans les villes moyennes
dans la ruralité
un dernier mot sur ces questions de
logement la question des squatters
évidemment vous avez promis un
observatoire des squats il sera créé et
qu'on alors je réunis tous les préfets
de département la semaine prochaine pour
leur demander des chiffres et dès que
nous aurons des données consolidées
france entière nous pourrons les publier
ça sera le début de cet observatoire
j'espère d'ici la fin du mois
j'ai demandé à chaque préfet de me faire
un retour sur l'application de la
nouvelle loi
j'ai déjà les premiers chiffres pour
paris je sais que onze expulsions
locatives de file pas locatif pardon aux
expulsions de squatters de résidences
principales ou secondaires ont eu lieu
avec le concours des forces de l'ordre
depuis le début de l'année à paris j'ai
besoin d'avoir les chiffres ailleurs
hier j'étais dans le nord le préfet m'a
dit qu'il y avait une affaire qui avait
qui leur avait été signalé qu'ils
avaient réglé pareil avec une expulsion
donc ce sont ces données consolidées
dont j'ai besoin on va parler des
régionales évidemment avant de parler de
l'île de france on a parlé des remous
provoqués par l'interview de jean castex
dimanche au jdd
annoncé que la liste de la majorité
présidentielle se retirer au profit de
celle de renaud muselier
on va pas refaire le feuilleton chez les
républicains mais ce matin sophie cluzel
la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle dans cette région sud
annonce que finalement elle maintient sa
liste est ce que le pré le premier
ministre a fait une erreur voire une
faute politique dimanche
comme l'a dit sophie cluzel ce matin le
premier ministre a répondu à une main
tendue de renaud muselier qui proposait
différentes sensibilités qui peuvent
porter un projet ensemble pour la région
provence alpes côte d'azur de se
rassembler et sophie cluzel elle est
toujours dans cette logique c'est ce
qu'elle disait ce matin
elle souhaite que la majorité
présidentielle soit représentée dans
cette élection et qu'elles soient
représentées c'est ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure avec un projet un projet
défini travail et porter pour les
habitants de cette région et donc on en
l'air pour vous que jean castex accepte
la main tendue de renaud muselier
moi je pense plutôt que le problème ce
sont les ambiguïtés ou la fin des
ambiguïtés à travers le mouvement des
républicains
quand on entend dans le même parti eric
ciotti dire la seule chose qui nous
différencie du rassemblement national
c'est notre capacité à gouverner et par
ailleurs des membres de ce parti qui
d'ailleurs l'ont quittée depuis dont
l'engagement contre le rassemblement
national est claire je pense à christian
estrosi je pense à hubert falco je pense
aussi à renaud muselier
on voit bien à quel point cette famille
politique n'est plus une famille
politique et se déchirent et donc moi
c'est surtout ça qui m'a frappé notre
engagement l'engagement de la majorité
présidentielle il est extrêmement claire
face aux extrêmes et aux risques que
représentent le rassemblement national
finalement ce débat a aussi montré qu'il
y avait de droite dans l'est républicain
et d'ailleurs certains en ont tiré les
conséquences en sortant des républicains
est une femme de gauche manuel wargon
dans les bouquets tout à leurs fins
l'instant et toute cette élection
régionale dans l'impression qu'elle
tourne autour de la droite
ça vous inquiète par rapport à vos
convictions personnelles des territoires
de progrès
auquel j'appartiens est bien représenté
dans beaucoup des listes de la majorité
présidentielle c'est vrai en ile de
france
mais c'est vrai aussi dans d'autres
régions et à charge pour nous de faire
des propositions dans les champs qui
nous intéresse la solidarité c'est pour
ça que je fais une proposition dans le
cadre de cette campagne pour un revenu
d'urgence pour les jeunes
on a d'autres propositions expression
sur la durite auriez dit on a quand même
l'impression que la majorité
présidentielle elle penche clairement à
droite
non je pense qu'à la fin on arrive à
faire joujou la jambe gauche de la
majorité aura un temps d'arrêt à la
faire vivre le débat se débat il peut
avoir lieu aussi avec la partie la
partie gauche de l'échiquier politique
on a vraiment j'étais très intéressé par
l'interview de bernard cazeneuve d'or je
crois que c'était l'express il ya
quelques jours
disant qu'il fallait que les gauches
aussi clarifient leur positionnement par
rapport à l'extrême gauche
donc ce débat il existe dans tous les
endroits de l'ess que la majorité
présidentielle si elle n'a pas clarifié
son positionnement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on l'a vu cette semaine n'y a pas de
ligne claire dans la majorité président
général du tout la majorité
présidentielle en provence alpes côte
d'azur comme ailleurs a dit nous on est
prêt à travailler avec des forces qui
sont réellement républicaine qui sont
réellement engagés contre les extrêmes
que ce soit des sortant issu de la
droite où d'autres et donc de toutes
façons ces discussions continueront dans
les différents villages et dimanche
sophie cluzel dimanche soir qui
cliquerez sur tous les plateaux qu'elle
soutiendra nos mesures et qu'elle fera
la campagne avec lui et que le vendredi
matin à l annonce qu'elle fera campagne
contre lui est ce que c'est quand même
pas un problème quand la majorité
présidentielle moi j'ai écouté sophie
cluzel ce matin et je les ai entendus
dire que l'important c'était le projet
et que la majorité présidentielle soit
représentée et je crois vraiment qu elle
a raison le débat ça ne peut pas être
qu'un débat de personnes ça doit être un
débat d'idées et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j ai contribué avec une
proposait de l'année allemagne fait sur
l'île de france vous apportez vous
apportez votre soutien à sophie cluzel
clairement ce matin à votre collègue son
pipi z par définition on énorme du même
gouvernement
j'apprécie beaucoup sophie cluzel et
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
l'année dernière
l'alsace la relance de strasbourg
l'européenne fabrice merci beaucoup
[Musique]